right this is ytterbium again the
lanthanide stored in a very old glass
bowl handwritten label ytterbium is one
of the handful of lanthanide elements
which is stable and not only the +3
oxidation state but also the +2 in fact
it is exceptionally stable in the +2
state which is very unusual for a
lanthanide so this is your terbium and
it's a very very old research sample and
you can see that the label is
handwritten yeah we use your terbium
quite a lot because the +2 +3 oxidation
states they're really easy to push
compounds between both of them now the
ytterbium again is a very very low
element from the bottom of the periodic
table is very reactive and it should
really be stored under an inert
atmosphere of nonreactive argon now I
think originally this sample probably
was but you can see that it's got a
small Cork in the top so I think a
little bit of oxygen is leaked in a
little bit of air and it's caused the
ytterbium to become very very dark and
tarnished so there's ytterbium metal
coated by a small sample of the oxide
but the ytterbium metal against a very
good sample ytterbium it's it well it
depends on whether you talk about the
metal or as an element often you terbium
two compounds are sort of yellows and
oranges where do I get it from buy it
from a catalog you terbium is one of
three lanthanides which was named after
a swedish town called Euterpe which is
where they were all discovered terbium
erbium and terbium were all derivatives
of that town name the town stood very
well out of it yeah no not personally
yeah I should